manifestation is a real thing dude like
I think about how many is it things
because I believe that is who is it no
no no no no no listen I believe the two
I really did I believed it too oh you
believed it I believed it okay but then
it's like so things will happen in your
life that you didn't manifest
right right so the last you know that's
a couple of months things were happening
that I didn't manifest I remember I
didn't visual you know I mean it wasn't
a part of my thing in a positive way in
a negative way I wrote something about
manifesting but keep going okay so
whenever like something really bad
happens that I didn't manifest I'm like
oh manifestation doesn't work but
usually I think I believe everything
that I have is through manifestation
um
okay I I have just I'm just gonna push
back on manifest okay and we're gonna
have to fight against her just fight me
fight me on this okay that's basically
like I read this because I I kind of
feel similarly where
um like they're I'm like this happened
to me I I swear in my heart like it's
because I thought it I believed it and
now it's happening right but this is
what I read about manifesting it says
basically
it's all about privilege luck and timing
like it's by all means think positively
believe in yourself follow your dreams
work hard because a positive attitude
and optimistic Outlook will never be a
bad choice and will only ever serve you
well in your life and your relationships
but better finish but
but
um it kind of really is like a false
reality to soothe US during difficult
times because manifesting things and I
want you to think of the family whose
daughter was killed tonight
imagine who do I know they just imagine
saying that to them I want you to think
of of people whose family members have
been diagnosed with cancer and tell them
they didn't think positively enough and
that's why this is this has happened I
don't believe in that though I don't
believe that yeah and so we can't
control a huge portion of life my friend
Robert's got a fire argument
bad things can happen to good people
good things happen to bad life happens
life happens people can work their whole
lives with passion and integrity and
still never make it to where they want
to I agree and um it's so I I
there are parts of manifestation that I
think like are true like if you think
positively and you direct your mind in
that direction clearly it's you know
it's things are bound to happen for you
but like but it's the same thought of
God right like you know if you if you
look at like you know a school shooting
for instance right you think to yourself
there's there's no way there's a God why
would that happen there's no lessons to
be taught yeah I mean that's a [__]
terrible thing right but it's like I
still believe it in God you know what I
mean yeah I feel it it's a feeling you
know I mean and it's like um and I see
it working in my life you know I mean so
it's like you know life happens I mean
when Christians go I'm not a Christian
but they're like you know I mean well
you know you know there's a reason why
that happened we don't know God's missed
if there's a mystery I don't know those
things there's a million mysteries in
life I'll never figure out right but
it's a feeling go ahead Robert
okay
um
that was a weird swim all right anyway
by the way I'm not disagreeing with the
idea of manifestation I just think that
like sometimes like you know like I grew
up in a third world country and there's
certain things that I've seen I'm like
people work hard here they do all of the
right things they are good Pious people
who like really have this like faith in
their life that things are going to get
better and then can I say something I'm
the main attorney contact for a second
but your main attorney but the manager
is going to say but let me just say
something yeah right this is that like I
know the kind of upbringing you've had
right okay violent painful and you guys
came to America right yeah and you guys
had no money right yeah you just sit on
my fisted by my family doctor okay you
don't have to say the fisted part right
okay that's deep yeah it was deep so far
it went for to do it no I'm kidding um
is that um but so you've had right but
can I say something when I first met you
I went before I even contact you on
we've been on Tinder fire I went back I
went back into your like account right
and you were always doing sketches and
you were doing like trying to DJ you
know what I mean
wait you did sketch copies excuse me we
got some popcorn yeah you would do some
scene with gardo where there was one see
what you're doing with a joke comedy
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you
were a DJ yeah yeah and I saw another
thing where you went you had bought like
a God had bought like a DJ thing right
and you guys were like yeah
it's a fact right so you've always
wanted to do something creative I think
you were a dreamer go ahead
[Laughter]
be a dreamer but to your point when I
was busy you manifested
when I was in the thick of my family
dysfunction when I was getting my ass
beat regularly when I was being diddled
by uncles who weren't supposed to ditto
me I remember just completely
dissociating and there's this area in in
my city called Fuente osmania and that's
where all the Billboards were and I
remember just looking at one it was a
guest billboard and everybody I remember
thinking like I'm gonna be something I'm
gonna get the [__] out of here I'm gonna
be something I'm gonna be something so
yes I do believe that you know
um you can't obviously just manifest
things into existence but you can
believe it hard enough that your body
just naturally moves in the way to get
you that's what we mean right but but it
doesn't happen for everybody there's a
reason
there we go Dog go get it get it so
manifestation what I believe is with
persistence determination realism and
wanting success more than your next
breath a person can literally attain
anything I believe this I'm a person
who's come from absolutely nothing
poverty my house was a third world
country that's like what it was like
where I lived you know what I mean I
ain't saying it's that deep but I'm
saying like hunger Hunger no money
nothing pain Devastation nothing I had
nothing we had nothing get her get her
no I'm not trying to get her why are you
getting her so hard right now dude no no
what I'm saying is there's another part
of this so for years I would always go
persistence determination realism
because I never was like oh I want to be
a rapper y'all boats and [__] and
hoes I never thought that I was like you
know what
this is a very big space and Alan Watts
said anything you can be interested in
you will find others who are and I look
I look man right no I'm saying like
you're cute as [__] I'm black but I look
white I don't fit in I like science
fiction and Anime and like all this
nerdy [__] in hip-hop and all my come up
everybody just clown me I would talk
about my emotions and my feelings and
they made fun of it they made fun of it
but I knew I was like there is a space
for this and there are people out there
so the biggest Factor there when um
thinking about myself is a brand and and
creating something larger than myself
the big piece there is realism so to be
realistic in your goals and what you
want so to be one of the biggest rappers
ever which I am I'm one of the biggest
rappers ever
I had a goal of how to attain that but
there's another thing here and then I
want to get on the on the quote-unquote
negative aspect of it there's another
thing that I then realized only recently
in my early 30s that a person needs to
be prepared for it they need to
literally be willing to know and
understand because it is a language
success manifestation it is a language
and I could sit here and tell the
viewers and the listeners all you have
to do is have persistence determination
realism and want success more than your
next breath and they could go okay and
they could understand that
but to know what that means as a
successful person to know that you have
to put everything into that and be ready
is another thing so with when it comes
to negativity
um I don't think that a little girl
dying of cancer has anything to do with
manifestation but I do personally and
that's no slight but I do personally
believe that our negative thoughts also
manifest and there is a difference
between an intrusive thought like oh
[__] I might go bankrupt or oh [__] I
hope my little baby doesn't fall all the
way down the stairs and hurt himself
there's a difference between like those
thoughts that are fleeting and we go
that could happen but let's not focus on
it there are people who focus on it they
focus on being broke they focus on the
negative aspects of their life because I
was one of those people I've done it and
I've lived in the negativity and just
watched it consume me and nothing was
happening and I was blaming everything
wrong in my life on somebody else or
because of this and if only and when I
stopped doing that when I stopped
comparing myself to others and when I
stopped manifesting negative energy and
I focused on the positive that was in my
life I saw a complete and utter change I
think there is a difference between
manifesting the lives that we always
dreamed of I.E yourself in entertainment
because you're snapping girl get it
thank you and then a little boy dying of
leukemia I do think that there's there's
a difference there and I think some
things happen and we can't explain them
and very much so like me coming up and
making it out of my situation
I can't explain it and I don't need to
explain it it is what it is whether it's
beautiful or whether it's
heart-wrenching it sucks but we got to
keep it pushing yeah we rest our case I
don't know about that
so I just think there's a language I
think manifestation is real because
check this [__] out let's really think
about this you guys so where'd you get
that Kill Bill poster outside the big
one the [__] that's one of my
favorites one of my favorite movies it's
the first thing I saw when I walked in
here